And so when you...
and so when you
stepped out of Serotonin
to start your own,
to start Chipped,
what was going on?
Like what was the
catalyst point that you're like,
I got to go into
business for myself?
This woman tried to
steal it from me.
I'd never built
a supply chain before.
So I was working
with this woman
who has gone through
like A16Z speedrun,
had a lot of accolades,
respected her, I looked
up to her a lot.
I went to her with,
Hey, I had this idea
for this product.
I want to build it.
And she was like,
why don't we work
on this together?
It can be a collaboration.
Refused to send
me any documents.
Everything just got really weird,
lasted like six months.
It got to the point
where when we did
New York Fashion Week,
we were like a partner
with this brand called Dauphinette.
We're on the runway for them.
There was like
a Vogue interview
and it was said like,
Chipped, founded by this woman,
and I was like,
what the fuck?
All the other magazines
that then like followed
and covered it.
So I'd been completely
written out of that narrative.
And then she offered me
a job for like
$90 grand a year
and 10% of
my own company.
So I was just
like, fuck you.
Let's go raise some money
and do this myself.